we look at every subject that we want to
film and then we say but what is the
best way to get into their world it's an
amazing moment when you realize that
you're actually seeing some stuff for
the first time my name's John downer and
these are my incredible between x-bike
leadership well I suppose it all started
when I started baking wildlife films and
I wanted to have that kind of intimate
perspective to get into the animal world
and actually know what it's like to be
enough over the years use technology to
get more and more inside the animal
world and the stink has progressed we
would move from just using remote
cameras disguises rock to where we are
today which is having you know he's
incredible spy creatures which are able
to do filming cameras in their eyes
really look like the animals and the
animals were interacting them the whole
idea of you know using the robots came
about when we made a film about penguins
the first time you thought well what if
we made a Pinklon can of living movie
camera will look like a penguin that was
able to go into the colony and bark
again an incredible shot you can't
explain it because it's a dream come
true
I think part of the whole technique is
is to try and get inside the animal mind
you know understanding animal behavior
is key to it already we look one pipe up
to a wall by tortoises watched by an
elephant and I think it's something
about the fact that they look living
makes them think before they actually do
anything and if it's not a threat then
they kind of requite like in the
challenges or they are innumerable
because everything is a challenge from
the beginning to the point you gonna
film the animals once you get there and
once you vote actually with them they
tend to be the least of all the problems
they usually do deliver because they do
amazing things and if you've got the
technology there for film close to the
means in their world you know you want
you know you're going to get something
remarkable
you
[Music]